hey there everybody welcome to ask a
career coach my name is Martin McGovern
and today we are pulling together the
Internet to answer your your biggest
career be requests they hover letters
how do you write a good one are they
necessary all the ins and outs of the
cover letters so if you have questions
about cover letters start putting them
in the chat right now we got Karen in
the chat she'll be collecting all of
your questions and passing them along to
me throughout the conversation a couple
things to know I am NOT a developer so
there are some technical questions that
I won't be able to go into as much
detail on as I would hope but for all
the other questions around how to apply
for jobs how to network how to interview
well all that stuff let's get into it I
realize my microphone is actually on the
wrong setting so I'm going to change
that real quick so that we have a little
less of an echo I hope that sounds good
on your end and we'll be getting into
the questions in just a minute I'm gonna
wait about five minutes before we jump
all the way in because we just want to
give people to join time to join from
around the world so if you are joining
the chat right now give us a shout let
us know where in the world you are
joining us from and if you are a
returning viewer or if you are a new
viewer I'm curious to see all the
familiar faces as well as everyone who
is joining us for the first time excited
to jump into our topics today so let's
get the conversation started
all right we got we got folks sharing
their Instagram so if you want to
connect on Instagram go check them out
we got a hey there from Indonesia
welcome artists Austin Texas is my old
stomping grounds I'm joining us from
Chicago today it's actually pretty brisk
and nice out today all right we got
someone a fourth a fourth session
returner thank you for coming back four
times to ask questions and engage in the
group oh we got we got on cush coming
from the initial days of the initiative
I love the alliteration there thanks for
joining us
looks like you're all recognizing each
other as well I love it one of the great
things about these sessions is you can
actually connect with each other and
support each other outside of our QA so
if you have a LinkedIn profile or some
other way that you'd like people to
connect with you and stay in touch
please share it in the chat and we can
all keep in touch with each other
we got Muhammad for
Egypt it's their first time on the
livestream today thanks for joining us
we got Sivan II from India first-timer
Sanjeev it's a fourth time er thanks for
joining us again it's midnight in India
dang ya'll are staying up late I love it
Atlanta Dominican Republic oh wow
we got people from all over the world
joining us again it's so exciting to be
able to hear your questions and offer
the you know as much advice as I can
again this is more of a conversation
than a dictation so if you have other
ideas that you want to share in the chat
if things pop into your head you're like
I've encountered that here's a link
share it help everyone out we're all in
this together
so don't feel like you know I'm the one
with all the answers we all have a lot
of knowledge that we're bringing to the
table a lot of different types of
experience and if we work together we
can really help each other build an
amazing career so we're about five
minutes in we'll be getting started with
the initial question and I'm gonna just
give a shout out if you have career
questions on your mind already whether
they're related to cover letters or not
start putting them in the chat and Karen
will be passing them my way
[Music]
looks like we got a couple of questions
coming in alright everybody we're gonna
start with the question of half of what
makes a great cover letter what makes a
great cover letter it's a big question
and it's changed over the years
I actually saw something pretty funny on
LinkedIn this morning someone had posted
a resume from 1950 now I don't know if
it's true or not if it's real or not but
it was pretty funny looking it basically
had the person's name their height their
hobbies which was like weight lifting
and the fact that they were in the army
and that was the entire resume and the
joke that I think someone wrote maybe
it's real maybe it's not was that they
got twelve off course um who knows right
but it was a really funny thing because
it just kind of shows the complexity of
the job search and how it's grown over
the years you know back when my
grandparents came to the United States
what my grandpa had to do was basically
get some tools go to a bricklaying site
where they were building a building and
say do you need help putting up that
wall I mean that's the best networking
ever right you go straight to the hiring
manager and you see if they need help
and it was all about them but that's
really all he had to do he never had to
you know create an account on LinkedIn
because computers weren't really a thing
back then so what we are trying to do
with all of this work that we're putting
out there and creating with all these
profiles and all these applications is
we're trying to get to the decision
maker right that's what we're really
trying to get at at the end of the day
and so the question is how do you get
closer to the decision-maker and how do
you convince them that you're the person
that can help with the job well the
first thing you need to do is make sure
that you are writing everything from the
perspective of I'm here to help not from
the perspective of I want a job and the
way you do that is you change your
language a little bit most people start
their cover letters with I or me or my
name is right
these are triggers that show an employer
that you're not really in it for them
you're in it for yourself and if we're
going
into the job search with that mindset
with Amy first mindset and not a you
first or them first mindset we're going
to be putting ourselves in a
disadvantage because when they ask his
questions like why do you want to work
here we're gonna say because I want to
get paid right that's a cliche it's like
why do you want to work here well I want
money to pay rent okay great but what
makes you different than the next person
so what we want to do is really think
about these companies that we're
applying for and the reason I bring this
all up is because one of the reasons
that people don't want to write cover
letters is because they're just sending
mass applications out through these job
portals and they say well I don't want
to spend a whole bunch of time writing
cover letters if they're not even going
to read them well that's a fair point
they're not going to read them if you're
if you're not going to put the effort
into the application why should they put
the effort into reading your application
think about it if you are only going to
spend ten seconds applying to a job why
should they spend any more than 10
seconds looking at your stuff and so
that's where we have to really change
our perspective we should really narrow
the types of companies we're looking at
and batch them so that we can be more
specific with our outreach we should
know people who are at the company we
should write good cover letters and we
should apply knowing that maybe this is
the right role but if not there could be
other ways that I can help if you go in
with a how can I help mindset
opportunities open up so instead of
writing a cover letter from the
perspective of me me I I look at me we
write it from your company is trying to
do these amazing things I'm also working
on building those technologies and
working towards that awesome ideal
future whatever the thing is that
they're trying to build together we can
actually do some really some really cool
things so first paragraph and keep them
short you're up to all these amazing
things second paragraph I am also really
interested in those things and here's
some examples third paragraph together
we can make these projects happen so
that's a really interesting way
to say you mean us instead of me me give
me write so I want us to think about
that when it comes to the cover letter
and when it comes to any networking
outreach that you're gonna do in general
and another thing that you want to think
about when it comes to cover letters is
length now length is a hotly debated
topic in the career coach space some
people say you know a two page three
page resume is totally fine
I personally coming from a marketing
background understand that people will
not spend time reading and will just
basically skim through things and the
shorter you can make it the better think
about a pamphlet versus an ad write an
ad is easier to quickly understand than
a pamphlet so it doesn't mean that
there's not you know use a usefulness
for pamphlets if you're sitting in a
doctor's office and you have 20 minutes
to kill but if you're trying to get
attention fast you really need to make
it concise and the same thing goes for
cover letters when cover letters first
came out they were actually letters
because we would mail in our resume to
companies so we would write a cover
letter
we'd stack it on top of our resume we'd
fold them over each other put them in an
envelope stamp that ence and that in and
doing that is going to and sorry we have
some noise in the background here and
doing that is going to cause you to make
a very formal cover letter so a very
formal cover letter is dear madam or sir
with a date and a address and all these
different things which is what you would
actually do in a letter you know back in
the 80s or something but we don't live
in that world anymore how many letters
have you sent out in the past two months
probably not a ton maybe your rent
paycheck I don't know so or your rent
check I don't know so what we want to do
is mimic the way that people are
actually talking nowadays and the way
that people actually communicate so of
course this depends on industry and
depends on company and depends on a lot
of different things if it's a very
formal company you want to be a little
more formal if it's laid-back startups
you want to be a little more laid-back
but think about how we email even five
to ten years ago when you would do a
cover letter you'd write a full-page
cover letter and you'd fill all that
space because we were writing long
emails with many paragraphs and then
people got sick of that kind of
communication people stopped reading
emails that were more than a paragraph
to three paragraphs long and even three
paragraphs is pushing it on an email
these days if someone sends me something
that has five different things in it I'm
not gonna read it you need to have one
point per email right and in as we get
into this world of Twitter and different
things like that we start to realize
that the more concise you can be the
faster you can make your point the
easier it is to understand what you're
trying to say in the first place and
help you out and so when you think about
a cover letter try to keep it to three
paragraphs three short paragraphs or
less at least in my opinion I'm sure
there are caveats here and I'm sure
there's other ways to do it but I just
know from experience and from talking to
recruiters that they're probably not
going to read a full page dissertation
about your work history so I like to say
make the first paragraph about them this
is what you're working on and why it's
exciting this is the second paragraph
about you this is what I'm doing how it
relates to what you're doing and why
it's so exciting maybe give an example
of some of your work and then here's
what we can do together relate it to the
job at hand and say I can't wait to
continue the conversation and work with
you so I just laid out a whole lot of
cover letter stuff I know it was
probably a real fire hose for you but if
you have more questions about the cover
letter please put them in the chat
karen'll forward on my way and we'll get
in even deeper to each one of these
topics
[Music]
one last thing so I'm looking at the
chat here does every cover letter have
to be this amazing unique story that
you've written from scratch I don't
think so I think you can actually
formalize quite a bit of it especially
if you have a very specific job search
in mind like I know I want to work in
this industry at companies like these if
you know you want to work at this in
this industry at companies like these
most of them will have the same mission
the same goals so you can actually
create a form cover letter that
addresses generally that industry and
then you can switch out the names maybe
change some of the specifics and be able
to customize more quickly than starting
from scratch every time and I'll
actually give an example of a really bad
cover letter that I wrote back in
college
this probably 2008-2009 I wanted to work
at a large advertising firm in Chicago
and I gosh I'm thinking back on it right
now and it's so lame
what I did it's so lame I wrote this
like almost three page two to three page
like essay and I think they had some
like essay questions in their
application process but it was like back
when I was a little kid and I was
watching TV I saw this commercial and it
was really inspiring and I like told
these really long detailed stories and
it wasn't that great of a writer so it
was like it would dragged on I I almost
want to go back and find that see if I
can find that somewhere in an old email
or something and just see how how bad it
was and just realizing like you know I
was in the mode of college right you
write three to five page three to 10
page three to twenty page essays about
like Irish history or something like
that so I was in the mode of writing
these very long drawn-out
essays and there's a big difference
between an essay for class and a cover
letter for a job needless to say didn't
get that internship so keep it concise
keep it focused and if you're if you're
trying to get in in touch with people
make it more about them than you
all right let's jump on into your
questions Raul how can I make my CV
better this is a great question all
right
your CV this is a really interesting
question because there are a number of
different things you can do I'll
primarily when I see people CDs or
resumes or whatever it might be the
problem that comes up is that they are
number one not well formula formatted
number two they are long they there
they're too much and they talk and they
include a lot of irrelevant things
number three they don't actually talk to
a person in a way that that person can
understand so let me get into a little
bit more of the specifics of that if
you're if your CV or your resume is not
well formatted because you just opened
up a word doc and started typing try and
go online and Google resume and CV
templates I I went to school for graphic
design that was my minor and even I used
templates in creating my resumes because
at a certain point you know back in
college when I was doing graphic design
I had a website that I built from
scratch a resume that I built from
scratch in Adobe Illustrator I think and
I had everything matching and everything
looking really solid and stuff like that
now at a certain point that gets to be
very complicated it takes a lot of time
every time you need to make an edit or
an update you have to change everything
on it a lot of people try to think of
their resume is an art piece or
something along those lines and unless
you're gonna go like way towards the
other end of the spectrum and create a
website that's like interactive
an interactive resume or something I
think templates are a really great way
to go because it's more about the
clarity of conveying the information
then the creativity in how you put it
together in my opinion now this is
different if you're in design this is
different in in a lot of different areas
but just in general for the majority of
people using a template is going to help
you save time and just make everything
much cleaner and so what I use Google
Doc templates and I customized it a
little bit you know the one I downloaded
have the picture on it so I took that
off and changed some margins and things
I could fit more information but in
general try to use things that help make
things easier to read so the same thing
with my website if you're not you know
building websites every day let's say
you're a marketer or something like that
try to use template sites use things
that make it easier to update edit and
change because what ends up happening is
people spend so much time worried about
formatting that they never actually get
it done and they never actually send it
out or they send it out with errors so
you want to be nimble you want to be
able to move quickly with the job search
you want to be able to make adjustments
and changes on the fly create a new
project add it to your resume create a
new thing add it to your resume moving
quickly is very important when applying
for jobs so how do you make it better
one thing could be to use templates the
other thing is to keep it short so that
people will actually read through it and
then the third thing what did I say
shoot I lost my train of thought oh the
third thing is make it tell better
stories a lot of our resumes especially
if you're in a technical space are
written for the way that you think about
your project used certain API - blah
blah blah then an HR person gets it
who's not technical and they have no
idea what your resume is saying right so
try to put it into context again your
resume is a bit more of a sales document
and just repository for all of your
technical information so when you are
thinking about putting together your CV
for each bullet point try and tell a
story if I were to ask you about any
single bullet point on your CV what
would what story would you be able to
tell me if the answer is I don't have a
story to go along with that well you
might want to take another look at those
bullets so for instance build an app
utilizing you know this program and this
API in order to create what so in order
to improve the users experience in order
to organize the let's say it's like a
sorting movies app so built an app
utilizing these these programs and API
is in order to filter movies for date
night or something like that make it a
little more maybe even date night is too
much but make it a little bit more of a
story that anyone can understand even if
they're not technical so one so that I
would I would definitely go down that
route try and format it in a way that's
easier and then try and tell the story
in a way that's easier for more people
to understand give your resume to
someone who is not technical and see if
they can understand what you actually do
if they can't you might need to add in
some more detail
all right I love this our next question
is from dev if we are not applying for a
paid job but a volunteer role do we
apply the same advice to the cover
letter I personally would I think that
the better you are at being concise and
making it about them the better
everything is and actually for a
volunteer organization you might want to
make it more about the cause that they
are that they are supporting and so even
bigger than any of these things though
is making sure you know someone at the
company if you don't know anyone at the
company it's hard to get a volunteer job
because who are you applying like what
role are you applying to are there
volunteer roles being posted online
there might be I found a few volunteer
career coaching jobs online for like you
know different types of communities and
so but I would I would I would
definitely push back and say how are you
finding these volunteer roles and who
exactly are you talking with because
that's gonna be the bigger piece of the
puzzle and then once you're actually
talking with someone you know write your
cover letter just just picture them in
your head be like what do they care
about you know they need help doing
these things I can help do these things
together we can accomplish this project
and that's gonna be how you really make
it stand out so I would apply the same
advice and then I'd also try and picture
who I'm writing it to because chances
are if you're trying to volunteer you
know you know someone at the company
yeah I'm gonna leave it at that
but if you have more questions around
that let me know I'm just trying to
picture the volunteer role that you're
going for and how that would play out
but I think that the same the same
points hold true all right
Sanjeev our cover letters always address
to a hiring manager or should we tailor
it according to the recipient if so how
should we tailor for example is it good
to add in technical topics depending on
who we're addressing follow-up question
what do you do what if you don't know
whom to address it to all right so this
gets into some of the nitty-gritty of
actually how do you put this together
and who do you send it to a lot of times
a cover letter in today's application
programs LinkedIn indeed things like
that it's a box that you fill out on the
application form or it's an attachment
that you include so how do you actually
do this most of the time we don't know
the name of the person that we are
sending this to even if we know someone
at the company or have met a hiring
manager or something like that there's
other people that might read this cover
letter how do you address it and I want
to preface this by saying there is no
one perfect answer but I can tell you
the way that I've started to think about
it lately and I think about it more is
like when you create a post on LinkedIn
or something like that when you're
trying to share something with a lot of
people you don't address it to any one
person so what do you actually say like
how do you address it I almost don't I
just move past the deer whomever because
I'm trying not to be that formal anymore
I don't think formality and cover
letters is going to be the way that they
continue to go in the future I think
they're gonna get less and less formal
just like most of the job search and so
I think just jumping right into the
first paragraph without a deer madam or
sir is probably the best way to go if
you're hesitant on that you could just
say you know do your hiring manager or
something like that I don't know that's
so hotly debated I will say I'm not a
hundred percent sure on what the current
standards are for this just because it's
changing so rapidly so if anyone has
suggestions of what they know
have worked for them for them put them
in the comments because I'm actually
this is one I'd like to explore a little
bit more and get a bit more varied
opinions on but I do think that for me
in general things are getting less and
less formal so what what could happen is
you just say dear hiring manager or - I
really don't like the phrase to whom it
concerns I think it's just so old-school
and doesn't anyone who reads that is
like what what era are we living in is
this a Shakespearean play I'm about to
read and so if you don't know who you're
addressing it to just say write it like
a general email hey comma and then jump
into it right I think that that's
probably the easiest way to still intro
it with a hey but then get right into
the meat and potatoes of it and not
worry too much and if your copy and
pasting it into the form on the job
application form you definitely don't
need to address it I think you can just
copy-paste it like an essay so yeah that
would be my recommendation there our
cover letters always address to the
hiring manager they're not sometimes
they go to HR sometimes they go to
hiring managers sometimes they get
passed around so I almost think putting
a very specific person's name on it
isn't always the best way to go leaving
it a little open-ended let's people sort
of digest it for themselves but if you
if you let's say you apply on LinkedIn
and you know the person that's going to
get your application they put that
person's face there use their name I
think that's fine and then how should
you tailor based on the recipient should
you add
more technical topics if you know it's
gonna be a technical person reading it
my gosh this is going to get really
detailed into it depends on all you know
so many different variables but I think
in general a cover letter is not
supposed to be an exhaustive document
hold the hyper technical stuff for the
interview and make sure what you're
getting across in the cover letter isn't
so much that you're you know this robot
who can be the most technical person
because then you're gonna end up writing
just paragraph after paragraph of
technical stuff what you're trying to
convey in the cover letter is that you
are excited about what they do and you
really want to help them do it better
and so if you can do that you're gonna
really set yourself up for success so
again first paragraph it's so exciting
to see a company like yours that's
trying to change the world in this way
utilizing these technologies second
paragraph I also utilize these
technologies in my work doing XY and Z
here's a project example and why I think
we'd be great working together paragraph
three
I can't wait to continue the
conversation learn more about the
company and see how best I can bring
value to the team make it more about
them make it more about you to working
together to solve problems and you're
going to be on the right track
all right
alright I'm cush I start my cover letter
by stating what I'm accept sorry I start
my cover letter by stating why I am
excited and passionate about this job
but I'm a fresher
I have no industry experience or
internship experience what do you
suggest
I'm actually not entirely sure what your
question here is Uncas I think it's
great to start a cover letter by saying
that you're excited and passionate about
the job like I said the way that I like
to think about it is talk about what
they're doing that's awesome talk about
what you do that relates and then talk
about how you can do it together but
that's just my format right I'm sorry
everyone's gonna have their own take on
it so if you want to start by talking
about how passionate you are about this
job as long as you're making it more
about them than you I think you're in a
good place now being new to the role and
new to the industry can you give us a
little bit more on what exactly the
question here is are you trying to say
like how do I back up my claim that I'm
excited if what you're trying to do is
back up your claim that you're excited
talk about the projects the personal
projects you've worked on so you need to
show how you're qualified all right so
if you truly have no experience to show
you might need to go build some of that
so you might need to create a couple
personal projects or do some volunteer
work or internship work or get a couple
of freelance clients or something like
that in order to be able to reference
those things in your both resume and
cover letter but if you just don't have
those things you still want to apply you
know what I would recommend is just
don't talk about that you know say this
is what your company does that I find
really fascinating I've taken a nano
degree or I've done whatever the thing
is that I've done that has prepared me
to help you in that pursuit and I can't
wait to work together so whatever it is
you have just referenced that if it's
not enough they'll tell you and then you
can either go get more
variance or you know find something else
that you think is more important to do
but yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't hold
yourself back necessarily just talk to
what you do have and you know just
because you don't have an internship or
something like that doesn't mean you
don't have knowledge so just talk about
what you're studying right now what are
you working on what are you trying to
learn what are you trying to build
there's so many different things in
different ways that you can put this
together
but I do think that give yourself a
little more credit just because you're
new to it doesn't mean you have zero
zero zero things to talk about
all right I'm just going through some of
these here all right
Adi how can I explain employment gaps in
my cover letter this is a really good
question
and I think again this goes down to what
how big is your gap what were you doing
during that gap and how do you want to
talk about it there was someone I was
chatting with once and they said that
they had this huge gap in their resume
and I was like all right well what were
you doing during that time and they said
I was a professional poker player it's
pretty new one I hadn't gotten that
before and I was like so why do you have
an employment gap if you were a
professional poker player for four years
they said well I don't want to put that
on my resume because I think that it'll
get looked at poorly by companies and
they won't want to hire me and I said
well what's more what looks worse an
employment gap where they can if you
really don't reference it they might
assume you were just sitting on the
couch watching Netflix at your parents
house for four years or talking about
your experiences professional poker
player which taught you how to read
people taught you how to manage your
finances taught you how to take risks
and make big bets you know use a little
bit of the poker terminology and also
might connect you with some sports
companies or marketing companies that
use gambling mindsets and different
things like that to create phone apps
and create different things like that so
we really dug into and I said you know
you might even be in an interview some
day talking to someone and they're like
I love poker I play poker every weekend
with my buddies and you can say well you
know why don't we start like a for fun
no money like poker tournament or one
for charity or something and do that as
like fun thing that in the office and
now you found someone in the company
that also likes what you like right and
you've just built a personal connection
over your work history so I do think
that your employment gap depends on how
you think about your employment gap if
you think neck
about your employment gap and you're
trying to avoid it they will think
negatively about your employment gap and
try to avoid you and so that's what I
would say I would really want to know a
little bit more about your employment
gap if it's let's say you know you
stayed at home to take care of kids
there are so many organizations out
there trying to help people get back
into the workforce after taking care of
their family if you were on sick leave
like that's okay that's something you
can mention if you're comfortable
mentioning it you can say like I was on
sick leave you don't even have to say
why or what'd you just say I was on sick
leave even I had to take care of myself
and my family for the past couple years
we can really we can be honest without
being like overly graphic or honest
right so we can talk about the reality
of the situation and the reality is is
that everyone's life has complications
everyone has different things that
they've done now if you're currently in
an employment gap if you're looking for
a job you don't have one right now you
got to start thinking about what you're
going to do today to change that gap to
close that gap let's say you're three
months into the job search you don't
have a job and all you're doing every
day is searching for a job when you go
into the interview they're gonna say
what have you been doing the past three
months if your answer is I've just been
searching for a job they're gonna say
all right well why didn't you try to do
anything else during that time why
didn't you volunteer anywhere join any
professional organizations of start a
meetup group work on a project build a
side gig any of these things that will
close that gap and just to give a
personal example when I quit my first
job I knew it would take about three to
six months to find a new gig so I
started hosting a monthly networking
event that was called idea lemon I did
it with a buddy from college in between
the networking events we would send
email campaigns and like resources to
people we would you know research
different types of projects we tried to
build like a journal that we might be
able to sell we did all sorts of
different things and then when I went in
and I interviewed for jobs they would
ask me about my previous job but then
they'd say well what is this
what were you doing the last three to
five months and I'd say oh well I've
been building this thing on my own and
I've been hosting these events I mean
like all right we don't care about your
last job we care about that that sounds
interesting and that's what we ended up
talking about and all these different
things so really sit back and say what
did I do
during that employment gap was I
volunteering at you know my my church or
something like that you can talk about
these different things in a way that is
interesting and related to the job so
sit down take a look at all the time
that you spent maybe you were like you
know rebuilding your basement or
something like doing like repairs or
remodels so you could sell your house
like that's a skill set that has
translatable things like I'm able to
organize I'm able to do a planning I'm
able to plan a project from start to
finish all these different things we can
always you know really squeeze the lemon
and find some relatable skills from what
people have been doing in their in their
gaps and so really take that time and if
you have if you'd like to share in the
chat hear what you've been doing I'd be
very curious to know
[Music]
all right
Sanjeev how can I show soft skills in a
cover letter this is a really good
question and I think there's a number of
different things that we can think about
in regards to this the first one is how
do I show soft skills soft skills can be
included in your Linkedin in your resume
and in your cover letter but again we
need to keep in mind what each one of
these things is for your Linkedin is
much more about the keywords and making
sure that all the keywords are there so
people can find you and it's a social
network so that you can stay in touch
with people with micro networking
interactions by commenting liking
sharing and doing all these other things
so that's really what LinkedIn is for at
a very basic level your resume is for a
quick scan of your employment history so
that I can see like where you're coming
from and you know maybe a few of the
things that you've done that are related
to this role and kind of get a sense
that like yeah you've been progressing
over time your cover letter is much more
about them and why you're excited about
them and what value you can bring to
them so it's not so much about listing
your skills and all those different
things it's more about mentioning skills
that will help with the role so if your
soft skill that you want to get across
is that you're a good public speaker
talk about the speeches that you've
given if the soft skill that you want to
like maybe presentations that you've
done if you're if what you want to get
across is that you're incredibly good at
programming talk about the programming
projects you've created but I would just
say like talk about one thing mention
one or two things that support it rather
than going into you know incredible
detail in the cover letter because the
incredible detail is what's supposed to
come out during the interview the
interviews where you can really get into
the nitty-gritty say like you know my
strengths are that I'm really empathetic
in the office I'm a really great
communicator I'm XY and Z and I think my
favorite thing with soft skills is
showing your soft skills don't write
about your soft skills show your soft
skills right so the way you respond to
email the quickness in which you respond
to their outreach and emails if they
give you a take-home assignment can you
get it done in 24 hours if if they say
you know if they're taking a long time
are you going to be following up every
single day or you're gonna give them
some space and check in once a week or
every other week what are the different
things that you are exuding in your
communication with them that will
showcase your soft skills and then if
you really want to show your soft skills
maybe create some content that also
elicits those those skills so you could
you know write an article and share it
on LinkedIn that talks about a time that
you have put your soft skills into
action to help with a project you know
there's a lot of different things that
you can do but I think at the end of the
day at the end of the day when you're
trying to get your soft skills across
and again this depends on the soft skill
it's better to show it than to say it
all right Mohammed what is the
difference between a cover letter and a
personal statement hmm this is a really
good one it's actually one I haven't
gotten in a very very long time so I'm
not entirely certain what a personal
statement is anymore and how that's used
so that's something I got to go do a
little more research on Karen maybe if
you have any thoughts on that that you
could add in the chat if not anyone else
who's in the chat please comment and
share any resources on personal
statements I think I think it might just
be a difference in verbage about the
same thing but in general I think you
know defaulting to what I've said about
cover letters and making it more about
them than you I think a personal
statement is is inherently gonna be a
little bit more me focused but if if
it's all just me me me me me you might
want to say how do i inject a little bit
more about them into this this statement
and if a personal statement is just like
this summary on your resume you know
it's it's more of a pitch so I I do need
to do a little bit more research so I
know exactly where personal statements
fall in the you know personal pitch
through interview ledger right we've got
your pitch your cover letter your resume
your LinkedIn your blah blah blah blah
blah all the way to the interview I need
to do a little more research there but I
think in general these topics still
apply these ideas still apply if you
have an example of a time that they've
asked for a personal statement and not a
cover letter please add a little bit
more information in the chat so we can
maybe dive deeper into it
[Music]
all right Ankush writes in could you
give an example of how I might relate my
limited work experience as a fresher
with a positions job duties well alright
so this is I'm gonna try and dig a
little deeper into this idea of being a
fresher because in general if you don't
have specific experiences that relate to
that role it's going to be tough just
like let's say it's a technical thing
it's gonna be tough to say you have
technical skills when you've never done
anything technical now that being said
if the position says you need to be a
leader you need to be someone who is
able to collaborate with different teams
if they're you know there's any number
of things that could say what you want
to be able to do is look into all the
different areas of your life in which
you've showcased these skills and this
is similar to the gap in your resume
right what are all the different times
that I have been a supportive person
right so let's say and this is good for
interviews too
they say what you know on a team what
kind of a player are you
generic interview question right you
could say well in my work I'm very much
a supporter I'm someone who you know on
any given project I will jump in where
needed to get the job done I can do a
lot of different things and I'm able to
support a lot of different areas that's
a very general work focused answer I
could also and this is just me speaking
about myself I can also talk about well
so let's say for work you know like hey
we need to do QH boom I can jump in I
can do those I've done that I can also
do emails I can also do a number of
things I'm kind of like a
jack-of-all-trades I can jump in now
take that and give a funnier example of
that right back when I did an escape
room with a bunch of my friends they at
the end gave us our personality type
breakdowns by the way that we were
interacting in the room and I was the
supporter I would jump in and help here
then I would move over here then I would
you know sing and dance to
keep the zombie from eating someone and
then I escaped him so these funny little
like you got to get out of the room and
solve a bunch of puzzles before a zombie
touches you and so like I would kind of
jump from place to place I would do a
puzzle I'd do some song and dance I'd do
all these different things that song and
dance help the zombies sleep it was a
weird day but what I can say is like use
that as an example and say like what
I've been told is that I'm a supporter
typically in a team I can also give an
example of feedback I've gotten from a
manager I can also give examples of in
my friend group I'm typically the person
that will jump on and go into any
activity wanna go laser tag let's do it
want to start a podcast let's do it
wanna XYZ I'm more of a supporter right
so it's how I get the same message
across using different parts of my life
all right friendships family work so if
you don't have specific of work
experience or let's say your work
experience is unrelated I have someone
who used to work in mental health and
now they want to work in programming how
do the ideas and the work that they did
in the mental health space translate
into this space well they're able to be
very patient with clients they can also
be very patient with sorry they can be
patient with patients and they can also
be very patient with client requests and
they have very good communication skills
to be able to interpret and then analyze
and then create solutions so you might
be able to relate experiences outside of
quote unquote
work experience that still relate so
take some online personality test like
sixteen personalities and see if you can
do see if you can pull out like really
pull out some of those core attributes
that you have that are really positive
that maybe you don't have any specific
specific work experience around yet but
still do relate to the position duties
I'm looking to soar sourabh I'm looking
sorry I'm I'm not I'm still learning how
to pronounce names so if I'm pronouncing
it wrong you have any resources on how I
can learn to pronounce names this is
very
way things I can't hear them but I
appreciate any help
sourabh I'm looking to do PhD in
robotics I'm not sure how to write a
great statement or statement of purpose
how can i integrate my nano degree
experience into it
well again I need to look into these
statements of purpose a little bit more
it sounds kind of similar to a summary
and things like that so what I might
recommend is that you say you ask
yourself why do you want to work in
robotics what is it about the robotics
industry that stands out to you what
technologies are coming out of the
robotics industry that you think are
going to have the largest impact in our
world so for instance I was talking with
someone who wanted to work in voice chat
right well they think that the the move
from you know your phone and visual
search to voice search is going to free
up people's time they're really excited
for the opportunity for us to seamlessly
interact with technology without having
our hand taken up so we have our hands
to do everything we want to do we just
talk out into the world and the world
gives us answers and they think that's a
brilliant future that they want to work
towards so when you're thinking about
your statement of purpose make it bigger
and and still specific right robotics
will help the world how and I think I've
given the example of the person who
wrote I want to eliminate all human
drivers from the road it's crazy
statement right but really what they're
saying is I want to make the road safer
if every car is a self-driving car that
has you know the ability to stop and
change lanes and all these different
things then you're going to be able to
live in a safer world with less deaths
and so you can actually get really
detailed on that you know like how many
lives has uber saved because teens
aren't driving under the influence
anymore
very cool stuff right so you're looking
to do a PhD in robotics you're not sure
how to write you
statement of purpose think about your
purpose so what is the end goal what is
the outcome of all this work you're
gonna do then narrow it a bit so I'm
really excited to do all these things
which is why I'm studying to get a PhD
in robotics and the reason I think
robotics are gonna have the biggest
effect on this outcome is because of X Y
& Z and I'm super excited to study it
here or work on it here because you're
doing X Y & Z and I really think that my
personality and my approach is going to
help you accomplish this and we're gonna
accomplish that within the bigger
picture and that's gonna lead to you
know a world that's safer because cars
drive themselves something like that
okay so when you're thinking about all
these things you got to think about
narrative you got to think about what
are we trying to get to what is the
hero's journey that we're on and how are
we getting there because most people
just say well I like technology and I
you know learned how to program it's
like well so does everyone who learned
how to program you don't really get
through this if you don't like
technology so go a level deeper and try
and think of now that I know how to
program how can I make an effect on the
world how can I work for a company that
builds things that help people because
that's really what we all want to do at
the end of the day we want to build
things that people use you want to build
things that no one uses so what is it
that you want to build for someone to
use and then if they use it what what
happens in their life even if it's like
a fantasy football app like how does
that help someone's life well they can
connect with friends they can have more
fun they can stay in touch you know all
sorts of different things so try and
think about in that in that perspective
and then we'll go I'll do some more
research on statement of purpose and
maybe we can get into it a little bit
more next week in the QA
and then we have two questions here
about how to integrate your nanodegree
experience Donna and Donna asks if you
have Udacity projects uploaded to github
is it a good idea to put a link to your
github in your cover letter yes I think
a header in your cover letter with your
name and your most prominent links are
is a good idea I think one of the things
that I've seen done is that you know on
your resume you have like a section for
links and you can put your personal
website and a number of different things
and then you can also in your cover
letter add those in the header or the
footer or wherever you might want to put
them maybe in the signature just put
some links to your github your LinkedIn
and some other places and then make sure
that your personal website your github
and your LinkedIn link out to all the
different things that you've built
alright our next question is from Raul
how can I get an internship I love this
I think we're gonna wrap up on this
question so it looks like we got through
almost all of them today I hope but yeah
if you have more questions of course you
can share them and we'll keep them in
mind for next week or bring them with to
next week's session which Karen will be
linking to if you'd like to sign up for
it after this call but how do I get an
internship you get an internship the
same way you get a job you need to
number one network number to improve
your application materials number three
apply to companies that you are
currently trying to build and network
into and number four create an online
presence that backs up all of the things
that you're saying so let's see if I can
remember those four and go into more
detail number one you have to know what
you want and you have to start applying
to those things I'm gonna go out of
order if to know you on you have to
start applying to those things where do
you want to work meaning industry and
let's say your favorite companies and
then who are their competitors and
collaborators and put together sort of a
mind map of all those companies so you
can start finding your way in who do you
need to meet you need to meet people who
are doing the job
you wish you that you wish you had right
now so reach out to interns go on the
LinkedIn people search and say who's
working in this industry let's say it's
a self-driving cars and who's an intern
I'm gonna go talk to those interns I'm
gonna ask them how they got that job I'm
gonna ask them if they like that job and
then I'm going to ask them who I should
talk to who do they recommend I connect
with in order to learn more they'll
connect you with their manager their
manager will say hey we are always
hiring interns let's bring you on board
you also want to have a great online
presence that can back that up and
application materials that are solid so
your application materials don't have to
be the greatest thing on the planet
Earth I used to think that I used to
think it all need to be perfectly
designed and all these things it just
needs to be easy to read easy to
understand and it's more of a checkmark
at the end of the day if they've met you
and they like you the best thing that
could happen is they look at your resume
go yeah that looks good all right let's
talk right what are your skills and now
you're in the interview process right so
figure out what you want start narrowing
your focus so that you can apply in a
very tactical focused way create your
online materials your application
materials so that they support what
you're gonna say in the interview and
then last but not least stay in you know
connected with people network comment on
posts do different things update your
LinkedIn update your profiles make sure
that your website actually shows what
you can do and if you do all these
things you're not only gonna be able to
get an internship you're gonna be able
to continue to grow throughout your
career typically people change jobs
every two to four years now it's kind of
crazy it's moving up and up and up so
it's not just about the first internship
it's about the the next five moves that
you make over the next 10 to 20 years
you know so I hope this was helpful we
have a link that we're going to be
putting in the chat to join us next week
so please sign up if you'd like to come
back out and
ask more questions anything that pops in
your head right after we hang up you're
like oh I wish I asked that and if there
is anything else that we can help you
with please don't hesitate to reach out
via you know our student support or
LinkedIn different places like that I
also highly recommend that you connect
with each other so if you have you know
your LinkedIn and you want to be open to
connecting please please share that in
the chat you can follow us on both
YouTube and on LinkedIn so you can
follow our LinkedIn page or go to
youtube and have following you'll get
all of our career tips as well if you'd
like to go check those out there and we
have a number of webinars coming up
related to careers that will be very
helpful for you as well we got some
noise starting up in the background so
I'm gonna wrap up today's call thank you
all so much for joining us it's been a
pleasure digging into what makes a great
cover letter with you and also getting
into our nice little Tanjung questions
that you know the job search is a rough
process so I just love seeing all of you
coming together supporting each other
asking questions and really trying to
figure these things out rather than
procrastinating and you know trying to
ignore the reality of the situation
which is we're all trying to learn we're
all trying to improve in our careers and
we're all trying to get to that next
level so good luck in your search feel
free to reach out to me with any more
questions and I wish you the best of
luck Cheers